bei jedem einkauf merkt man ist wir
bekommen weniger für unser geld die
inflation steigt die energiepreise
klettern in ungeahnte höhen die pandemie
in der klimawandel der krieg alles hat
seinen preis wir werden ärmer werden so
der wirtschaftsminister aber noch
steuert der staat gegen entlastungspaket
corona hilfen spritsteuer runter
kurzarbeitergeld 9 euro ticket die
schwarze null hat ausgedient alles wird
teurer
woher kommt das geld für die krisen
unser thema in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
guten abend aus berlin ich darf ihnen
meine gäste vorstellen hier ist
christoph meyer von der fdp
stellvertretender vorsitzender der fdp
bundestagsfraktion und obmann seiner
partei im haushaltsausschuss achtet eben
aufs geld und der ist auch
landesvorsitzender der fdp in bergige
nordirland ulrich schneider begrüßt ich
hab dich hauptgeschäftsführer des
paritätischen gesamtverbandes
und zugeschaltet ist uns professor
henning viertel er ist direktor des
centrums für europäische politik und der
ist auch im beirat des bundesverbandes
mittelstand und dazu noch professor für
volkswirtschaftslehre an der hamburg
school of business administration und
herzlich willkommen sexy heitmann ex ist
freie wirtschaftsjournalistin und viele
jahre hat sich für die ard von der
frankfurter börse berichtet jetzt
berichtet sie unter anderem für welt.tv
schönen guten abend herr meier viele
menschen fragen sich dass es ist
irgendwie ein aufwuchs plötzlich hier
gibt es ein sondervermögen zum beispiel
100 milliarden für die bundeswehr es
gibt geld für das für den klimawandel
jetzt natürlich für all die folgendes
ukraine krieges entlastungspaket ganz
banal gefragt woher kommt dieses geld
das geld werden am ende wir alle wird
die gemeinschaft
zurückzahlen müssen wir nehmen jetzt
zunächst erstmal
verbindlichkeiten auf wobei wir bei dem
sondervermögen unternehmensschulden wenn
man schon auf wobei wir beim
sondervermögen natürlich formal zunächst
erstmal kreditermächtigungen beschließen
wollen das sind also noch keine schulden
sondern erst wenn also tatsächlich dafür
material für die bundeswehr angeschafft
wird und das ist in der tat eine
entwicklung die uns natürlich große
sorgen macht wir haben durch corona 350
milliarden euro mehr schulden
aufgenommen wir nehmen jetzt in diesem
jahr mit dem haushalt mit dem ergänzungs
haushalt aufgrund des ukraine kriegs
noch mal 140 milliarden euro auf wir
haben mit dem sondervermögen bundeswehr
letztlich auch ein thema womit wir
versäumnisse der vergangenheit versuchen
aufzuholen das gilt auch für den klima-
und transformation von der ebenfalls
letztlich diese transformation
anschieben muss und wir müssen das sagt
ja auch der finanzminister christian
linder wir müssen im jahr 2 23 dazu
kommen dass wir die schuldenbremse
einhalten so schwer das wird weil wir
auf dauer an der belastungsgrenze dieses
staates ansonsten wären das ist aber
schwierig war eben nicht weiß was noch
kommen kann das ist richtig herr
schneider wer wird denn wenn man sagt es
wird jetzt geld aufgenommen werden wir
werden uns hilf mir verschulden das
müssen wir aber auch machen weil sonst
ganz viele andere menschen leiden durch
diese krisen und wer das ist ja das
argument wer wird ärmer durch diese
krise
also er macht kann er durch jemand
werden der arm ist also deswegen
wirklich manchmal business irritiert wir
werden alle immer weniger arm es wird
auch nicht ärmer und viele machen wir
uns nichts vor wir merken die krise die
preissteigerungen nicht wir haben in
deutschland seit extrem gespalten das
land wir haben menschen wir haben die
höchste sparquote seit jahrzehnten muss
man auch mal als wenn ich nur die
höchste armutsquote sind rekord auch die
sparquote ist ein rekord das heißt im
moment wird in deutschland richtig viele
auf die hohe kante gelegt allein während
der pandemie jahre ist das geldvermögen
auf den privatkonten also und auffallend
viel auf aktien etc ist von 6,5 auf 7,7
billionen geklettert das heißt wenn die
frage ist wer wird er muss und wir haben
die herma wir haben sind die
13,4 millionen menschen die unter der
armutsgrenze leben es sind auch die idee
knapp drüber sind die zu mindestlöhnen
arbeiten auch der jetzt angestrebte
mindestlohn von 12 euro hat dann diese
inflationsrate kaufkraft von 11 euro nur
noch der regelsatz in a 2
449 hat die kaufkraft von 416 das heißt
die merken dass richtig die kommen gar
nicht mehr bei monat bei anderen heißt
es dass die weniger sparen können das
ist erst mal alles und die höheren auch
nicht auf für zwei euro fünfzig schritt
um zu fahren also wer bugatti fährt
beispielsweise der wird jetzt nicht weil
der spritpreis auf zwei euro stiege
sehen der garage stehen lassen da ist
einfach geld muss man sehen
und wenn man das sieht dann kann man
glaube ich auch eine sehr zielgenaue
politik machen kann man gucken wie ein
mann entlarven
sie verschuldet er führte das heißt ja
jetzt immer so wenn man eben sagte der
bundeswirtschaftsminister
wir werden ärmer oder manche sagen ja
die fetten jahre sind vorbei die
zuwächse das wird es nicht mehr so geben
auf der anderen seite sehen wir ja es
gibt eine große nachfrage nach
produktion es gibt auch eine nach wie
vor niedrige arbeitslosigkeit also für
wen sind in ihrer meinung nach die
fetten jahre vorbei
na ja für uns alle natürlich also robert
habeck hat schon recht die der
wohlfahrts verluste ist real den den
tragen wir alle deshalb können wir auch
als gesellschaft als volkswirtschaft nur
um verteilen diese lasten aber wir
können sie nicht im grunde
weginflationieren sondern wir müssen sie
tragen irgendjemand muss sie tragen wir
können uns als gesellschaft nicht selbst
dafür
subventionieren oder kompensieren das
geht nicht deshalb ist es ja auch so
wichtig dass wir jetzt diejenigen
branchen aber auch haushalte die
besonders betroffen sind helfen das zu
überstehen das geht aber nur in dem
andere diese lasten eben mehr tragen als
andere aber diese reale wohlfahrts
verluste ist da und er hat sich
angestaut auch über jahre der krieg ist
natürlich jetzt sehr anders der der uns
besonders hart trifft die menschen der
ukraine natürlich um dimensionen
schlimmer aber die wirtschaftlichen
folgen tragen wie und dass es letztlich
muss man sagen auch eine folge einer
politik die die über jahrzehnte im
grunde dinge nicht gestaltet hat also im
grunde nur auch umverteilt hat aber
nicht wirklich die transformation der
wirtschaft vorangetrieben haben wir
haben die energiewende nicht so
ernsthaft vorangetrieben
die kosten zahlen wir jetzt die rechnung
zahlen wir und das ist der preis für
eine politik die zu wenig gesehen hat
dass wir dass wir sozusagen in einem in
einer phase realen wirtschafts verlust
und wohlfahrt verlust gehen freiheit man
ersehen sie ist denn wie bei der börse
geht es immer darum um ja um gewinne und
verluste wenn man es jetzt mal so auf
macht wer sind denn jetzt im moment die
gewinner und wer sind die starken
verliere
allem voran muss ich sagen ich bin
überrascht wie viel wohlstandsverlust
wir schon haben sollen wenn man das land
anguckt ist der wohlstandsverlust in den
letzten jahren ja allzu gross noch nicht
gewesen wir uns eben schon gehört wir
haben eben eine große schere und die die
wärme sind die spüren dass ganz enorm
und da sind auch hilfspakete kleinere
natürlich keine riesen hilfe weise über
eine dauer hilfe braucht aber für die
die das nicht zu spüren die haben auch
derzeit noch keinen grossen
wohlstandsverlust und bei den ganz
großen unternehmen da spielen wir viele
probleme die eben die korona krise schon
gebracht hat also zu
lieferschwierigkeiten zb die
globalisierung
fachkräftemangel also etwas wir sehen
jetzt durch den russland ukraine krieg
neue probleme verstärkte probleme vor
allen dingen durch die sehr stark
steigenden ölpreise das belastet erstmal
fast alle unternehmen kann man sagen
denn alle brauchen für die produktion
energie und sie brauchen natürlich auch
im zweifel für den transport energie und
das sind die belastungen für alle
unternehmen durch die branchen durch den
einen glas dauerhaft schwerer den
anderen erstmal weniger große gewinner
ich würde sagen es sind die branche auf
die wollte man vorher gar nicht
unbedingt schauen das sind die
rüstungskonzerne natürlich und natürlich
auch zuweilen ölkonzerne nicht alle
energiekonzerne denn die erneuerbaren
energien sind nicht alle so schon am
laufen wie man sich das wünschen würde
aber das zeigt eben wo es brennt und wo
etwas getan werden kann um wo auch
chance liegen in dieser krise dass man
da jetzt wirklich auch von der politik
konzepte macht die das angehen das werde
dann das wichtigste hier meinen wir das
jetzt so hören das ist dass der
wohlstandsverlust ja eigentlich für
viele gar nicht für einige ist sehr groß
und für ganz viele ist er war gar nicht
so groß wie sehr muss sich der staat
letztendlich dann um alle kümmern oder
müsste er sich nicht um ein paar
besondere da muss man glaube ich
ehrlich sein also ich habe mich die zahl
im kopf wie bugatti fahrer wir wirklich
in deutschland haben deswegen ist das
bild natürlich immer einfach gesagt aber
es ist halt so dass wir mit den
entlastungs paketen die die
bundesregierung aufgelegt hat in der tat
auch eine breitenwirkung erzielen wir
haben
37 milliarden euro hier jetzt in der
beschlusslage das ist schon etwas aber
man muss auch ehrlich sagen dass wir den
weltmarktpreisen an vielen stellen nicht
mit staatlicher unterstützung und
staatlicher hilfe eins zu eins hinterher
kommen können wichtig ist dass wir jetzt
uns darauf verständigen dass wir wieder
auf einen wachstumspfad kommen diese
sparquote die eben genannt wurde das
geld wurde ja früher konsumiert das
heißt früher wurde das geld hat nicht
auf die hohe kante gelegt das heißt wenn
dieser impuls möglich ist wenn die
lieferketten probleme aufgelöst werden
viele leute in den menschen das geld aus
dem innersten sicherheitsthema also die
sparquote geht immer dann hoch wenn die
menschen in unsicheren situationen leben
das war durch corona so das ist jetzt
durch den ukraine krieg oder durch die
bedrohungslage durch russland so das
heißt das wird sich hoffentlich in den
nächsten
monaten wann genau wissen wir nicht
zumindest dergestalt relativieren dass
hier mit einer sinkenden sparquote das
geld auch wieder anders in den
volkswirtschaftlichen kreislauf kommt
viel wichtiger erstmal noch die
lieferketten probleme und wenn wir dann
einen wachstumsrate haben die nicht bei
zwei prozent ist sondern wie es
ursprünglich ja sogar prognostiziert
vier viereinhalb prozent für dieses jahr
dann in den nächsten jahren dann werden
wir auch wieder andere spielräume in den
staatshaushalten haben momentan muss man
aber sagen dass der start am limit von
dem ist was er leisten kann und wenn wir
uns dann mal warum muss der staat wenn
er am limit ist dann menschen entlasten
ich gehe eigentlich genug haben die
frage ist ja am ende auch da mal eine
frage wo
entlastet man überall wenn wir sagen wir
wollen zum beispiel die menschen also
die frage ist ja wie kriegt man einfach
teil mechanismus hin denn nur den
wirklich bedürftigen teil wie sie es
formuliert haben betrifft und wie wer
definiert wer wirklich bedürftig ende
wie gesagt haben wir nicht nur bugatti
fahrer sondern ein ganz ganz viele
menschen die zu erfahren wir haben aber
leer wie ganz ganz
ausgeben für die gestiegenen
energiekosten um zur arbeit zu kommen
und es ist glaube ich eine frage der
fairness dass auch diese menschen einen
entlastungs impuls von uns bekommen und
dass eine koalition doch das hat die
ampel koalition also auf dem weg real
also ich denke wir machen machen wir
einmal konkret einen zweiten
entlastungspaket juni juli august senkt
über die mineralölsteuer gesenkt steuer
auf benzin und 30 prozent auf diese 30
cent um die auf diesel um 14 cent dass
da hat ja jeder was von egal richtig
aber derjenige der viel auch fahren
musste viel pendeln muss und das sind
die meisten menschen in deutschland die
haben davon natürlich überproportional
mehr ähnlich die von den neuen euro
ticket womit man im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr fahren kann ich
glaube es ist ein ausgewogenes modell
das alle betrifft die von diesen
energiekosten von diesen steigenden
energiekosten momentan in
mitleidenschaft gezogen sind die nach
dem hintergrund dass wir sagen müssen
wir können als staat nicht alles
auffangen das ist genau der punkt und
deswegen sollte der staat kann hier das
versuchen aber mit diesem
entlastungspaket wozu getan als kammern
das alles haben das kann einmal jetzt
vielleicht halbwegs gut gehen aber was
ist denn wenn die krise andauert wollen
sich im herbst nochmals 28 oder 23
milliarden ausgeben nur zurück die
stellung nehmen wir zum beispiel die
pendler wir haben insgesamt nur knapp 20
millionen kfz händler der größte teil
sind keine kfz pendler die haben auch
keine entsprechende mehrbelastung das
muss einfach singen wenn ich mir
anschaue
aber von frank von millionen 23
milliarden und die
zur entlastung sind nur zwei milliarden
tatsächlich zu bedürftigen hingegangen
zu wohngeld beziehen zu hartz 4 beziehen
und etwa auch zu kindern der rest wurde
insbesondere ich mir anschaue
steuererleichterungen 4,3 milliarden mit
einkommens proportionaler wirkung wie
man es nimmt das heißt derjenige der
meisten einkommen hat auch den größten
entlastungseffekt wenn ich mir anschaue
die 300 euro energie pauschale die an
alle erwerbstätigen geht wird zwar
versteuert bleibt aber eine million er
immer noch 162 euro über also müssen wir
das ich sagen es
ist ja auch hatte sich der staat denn
wirklich so dicke das ist doch der punkt
wir reden immer von sparen es wird immer
gesagt wir müssen gucken räder euro und
40 wird rausgehauen eine art und weise
dass man sich fragt wo ist da noch die
wirkung kann also die wirkung die
wirkung wird da sein wie gesagt wir
haben eine entlastungswirkung die mit 37
milliarden euro beziffert ist ich finde
es nicht redlich zu sagen dass wir nur
die wirklich bedürftigen die von
irgendwie man definiert wird in dem
falle von sie entlasten dürfte relativ
während die menschen wir haben gerade
über 20 millionen 21 millionen pendler
gesprochen haben sie offensichtlich wird
ja auch eher wie sie offensichtlich
nicht entlasten wollen wenn sie nicht
auch noch diese argumente
die haben ein breiterer eingerichtete er
erfüllte was wäre gerecht wen sollte der
staat entlasten wo er doch eigentlich am
limit ist mit seinen schulden
ja wir können das im grunde nur über
direkte einkommens transfers zielgenau
hinbekommen und wir dürfen auch nicht in
die preisgestaltung dermaßen
flächendeckend eingreifen also
energiepreise sind gestiegen das ist
ausdruck einer real gestiegenen
knappheit und wir können als stadt nicht
sagen die gibt es nicht sondern die die
ist real und irgendjemand trägt sie also
pauschal zu sagen alle gestiegenen
energiepreise die subventionieren wir
und wir tragen als volkswirtschaft keine
last mehr gestiegen knappheit was
energie versorgung angeht ist
schlichtweg unmöglich also das ist eine
logische fehlstellung aus deshalb gibt
es nur die möglichkeit die die die preis
wirkung wirken zu lassen also wirklich
diese knappheit indikation auch in die
märkte zu geben sparanreize verzichts
anreize zu setzen
und da wo es unmöglich ist dann wirklich
für für stark betroffene wirklich über
einkommens transfers zielgerichtet hilfe
zu leisten weil natürlich natürlich kann
jemand sagen ich fahre gar kein auto
sondern ich kann meine wohnung nicht
mehr heizen oder es sind andere dinge
und es sind ja in wahrheit auch nicht
nur die energiepreise sondern die
nahrungsmittelpreise wir haben
mittlerweile preisanstiege auf relativ
breiter front es sind 60 70 alle güter
und dienstleistungen des warenkorbes
hamm mittlerweile hohe preissteigerungen
und die produzentenpreise sind um 16 30
prozent gestiegen dh die sind noch gar
nicht beim verbraucher angekommen also
da da kommt noch eine zweite welle und
wir können unmöglich das altstadt auf
fang ist es ist logisch nicht möglich
ist eingetragen das ist ein einzige was
wir tun können ist diesen diese diese
die last umzuverteilen und und
diejenigen die starken schultern müssen
mehr tragen und wir müssen jetzt sehr
zielgerichtet und zielgenau die die
schwächeren schultern schützen
müsste sich da die politik ehrlicher
machen würden sie damit gehen in dem was
er sagt dass man einfach viel klarer
sagt ja dass die die kostensteigerung
die müssen wir eben jetzt alle tragen
ich glaube dass viele bereit werden die
kosten zu tragen die sie tragen können
ich glaube das erleben wir auch alle das
sehen wir selbst für uns so ich glaube
es gibt gruppen die brauchen ist
dringend und ich glaube dass man bei den
unternehmen schauen muss brauchen sie
brauchen sie es nicht denn wir dürfen
nicht vergessen der wohlstand unseres
landes hängt daran ob wir einen guten
arbeitsmarkt haben in starken
arbeitsmarkt auch für vollbeschäftigung
haben wenn es unternehmen trifft die
womöglich eben sehr viele beschäftigte
haben dieses vielleicht nicht so sehen
nicht die ganz großen unternehmen werden
zum beispiel in hessen ein unternehmen
das hat 3500 autos die jeden tag auf der
straße schulkinder fahren und behinderte
fahren die jetzt große probleme haben
weil sie die preise nicht erhöhen können
aber unglaublich hohe spritpreise zahlen
die jetzt kurz vor der insolvenz stehen
haben wir einen fall von dem man
vielleicht sagen könnte er dieses
unternehmen ist wichtig wir brauchen
dieses unternehmen wir brauchen auch die
arbeitsplätze dieses unternehmens und
wie können wir die retten also ich
glaube es braucht wirklich eine
strategie ein konzept wie man
unterstützung leistet zeitweise
unterstützung leistet und die stetige
viel glück kommt uns natürlich entgegen
dass auch ölpreise nicht nur eine
richtung kennen sondern im moment sieht
man ja dass der ölverbrauch weltweit
sinkt jena ist die größte lokomotive die
wir haben die verbraucher derzeit
weniger die konjunktur stottert da ein
bisschen weil eben die häfen von china
größtenteils immer wieder geschlossen
werden wegen corona maßnahmen und wir
sehen das entlastet natürlich dann am
markt auch wieder aber glaube das würde
doch das würde doch das ist grad wie er
aber das würde dann ja eher dafür
sprechen dass man eher den markt machen
lässt für mayr kur so sie darauf
vertrauen als liberale
ja selbstverständlich ich habe ja auch
eingangs gesagt und das möchte ich noch
mal klarstellen die bundesregierung kein
regierung der welt kann diese
gestiegenen preise für energie aber auch
für lebensmittel
eins zu eins abfangen diese 37
milliarden euro ist ein beitrag den die
politik leistet aber wir müssen uns das
haben sie ja in dem eingangs einspieler
in dem zitat auch genannt vom
wirtschaftsminister wir müssen uns auch
darauf einstellen dass alle die
gesellschaft ärmer wird in dieser
situation wenn wir in der tat sinkende
rohstoffpreise haben sinkende ölpreise
denn wäre das ein guter effekt ja dann
würden wir uns da alle freuen weil das
in der tat ein marktreaktion ist aber
ich möchte noch mal weil auch das eben
hier formuliert wurde und wir hier
darüber reden wer das alles bezahlen
soll wir haben in deutschland die
höchste steuer und abgabenquote im oecd
also im bereich der entwickelten
industrieländer
wir sind in der situation dass
deutschland die bundesrepublik
mittlerweile mehr als die hälfte seines
budgets für
sozialkosten ausgibt das heißt in der
bundesrepublik deutschland tut momentan
schon unglaublich viel um genau diese
umverteilung um genau diese soziale
sicherung zu finanzieren wir reden über
100 milliarden euro rentenzuschuss aus
dem bundestag ich sage nicht dass das
reduziert der diesel rentensteigerung ja
genau ich sage nicht dass das reduziert
werden soll aber es gehört zur fairness
dazu zu sagen dass das land hier schon
unglaublich viel tut und das wurde ja
auch eben erwähnt wir müssen eigentlich
dazu übergehen darüber zu diskutieren
wie dieses land zukunftsfähig wird die
investitionen angekurbelt werden können
dass dieses land wettbewerbsfähig ist
und eine mehr arbeitsplätze geschaffen
werden können damit die leute aus
eigener arbeit ihren lebens wäre es dann
konsequent zu sagen ja dann müssten der
auch die löhne erhöhen müssen wir
schauen dann sind das ist eine frage der
der tarif partner und wir werden
sicherlich in die situation kommen wir
haben ja die ersten anmeldungen
anführungszeichen oder verlautbarungen
von den gewerkschaften wir werden
sicherlich
lohnerhöhungen sehen wir sind in der
situation dass wir in einer
lohn-preis-spirale
vermutlich sein werden was eine
gefährliche entwicklung für die
inflationären tendenzen im nächsten jahr
sind aber wir müssen auf der anderen
seite auch das ist hier noch gar nicht
angesprochen worden auch da festhalten
dass als erstes die europäische
zentralbank was die inflationäre
inflationsraten angeht hier am zug ist
in amerika bleibt aber gehandelt und das
sind glaube ich punkte wo wir die
nächsten monate genau
er ist heute 23 schatten durch tage
richtig stellen erst in diesem
entlastungspaket werden über sechs
milliarden auszugeben durch die
vorgezogene abschaffung der eeg-umlage
um den strom für alle geliefert zu
machen lasst das wäre in diesem end last
moment in gießen refinanzierungspaket
wird alleine jetzt durch die
dreimonatige absenkung der energie
steuer werden etwa 34 milliarden
ausgegeben nur um benzin für alle
billiger zu machen das heißt es stimmt
durchaus was wir vorher gehörte kritik
das wären hier versuche gestartet seiten
der bundesregierung preise für alle zu
beeinflussen zu deckeln das der falsche
weg und auch zwei ganz kleine sachen es
sind nicht die hälfte dieses spezial die
ausmacht am bruttoinlandprodukt sollen
wir sind durch die pandemien moment auf
33 prozent einen riesenunterschied
geplant ist dass drei prozent
hochgegangen und die andere studie die
sie genannt haben bestimmt es gibt eine
hohe cd studie deutschland hat für
allein vor steuerte für singles die
höchste abgabenlast aber weil wir anders
aufgebaut als viele andere länder sobald
kinder im haushalt sind sobald ein
ehepaar da ist singt das von den in der
studie festgestellten 49 prozent auf 32
dann sind wir wieder vielen anderen
ländern
so gerne mal fragen zum einen die frage
nach lohnerhöhungen würde macht das dann
sinn wenn man mehr einen menschen können
sich das nicht mehr leisten ist dass der
sinnvollere weg anstatt dass der staat
ist alles gibt wäre das sinnvoller und
und was wäre das richtige instrument um
die inflation eben nicht steigen zu
lassen
wir zahlen mehr für energie das heißt
als meisterschaft wir geben mehr oder
dafür aus also wir können diesen effekt
nicht kompensieren inländisch durch
höhere löhne das haben wir den 70er
jahren versucht das hat hat zu höheren
inflationsraten
geführt dass wurde akkumuliert von der
von der zentrale von der politik die das
das gestützt hat auch ausgabenseitig
fiskalpolitisch oder den 70er jahren
gestützt das ist der falsche weg das
wissen wir heute so können wir das nicht
machen im gegenteil die die ezb das ist
ja angedeutet worden muss tatsächlich
jetzt langsam gegen steuern wir dürfen
natürlich keinen zinsschock also wir
dürfen nicht zu schnell dran gehen weil
auch die vermögenspreise natürlich an
diesen erwartungen niedriger zinsen
hängen aber inflation trifft natürlich
besonders diejenigen die eben nicht
automatisch über höhere löhne verhandeln
können und diese die schützen wir
natürlich durch dadurch dass wir die
inflation wieder runter führen die ezb
sollte die ersten ersten schritte gehen
aber aber behutsam weil wir eben auch in
dieser situation die auch sehr stark
durch unsicherheit durch wirtschaftliche
unsicherheit gecancelt gekennzeichnet
ist eben auch kein zinsschock
produzieren wir haben verschuldung der
stadt muss sich weiterhin verschulden
wir haben ruhe investitions
erfordernisse
wir müssen ihnen die in die energiewende
investieren wir müssen unsere sicherheit
investieren also das ist ja alles nicht
passiert und viele kollegen haben auch
immer wieder darauf hingewiesen dass
unsere leistungsbilanzüberschuss also
haben sehr viel exportiert aber wir
haben zu wenig in den eigenen
kapitalstock investiert und das fällt
uns jetzt ein bisschen auf die füße das
heißt ja das habe ich ja weg solange
dezidierte angebot politik weil wir
sonst diese
verteilungskonflikte auch nicht lösen
können über die inflation kommt dazu die
demographie der fachkräftemangel also
wir brauchen wieder eine eine stärkere
angebotspolitik um diese
verteilungsspielräume wieder zu bekommen
haben wir also zu lange frau heitmann
dieser schwarzen null festgehalten und
dadurch eben andere dinge versäumt eben
bestimmte investitionen nicht gemacht
glaube darüber sind sich die ökonomen
grundsätzlich nicht ganz einig ob eine
schwarze null eben was gutes ist oder
was schlechtes jetzt war es erstmal gut
wir haben ja auch viel gespart was wir
jetzt quasi wieder mit vollen händen
ausgeben können das können andere länder
gar nicht in dem maße auf der anderen
seite natürlich wo viel gespart wird
wird auch weniger investiert und war wie
eben mit der ezb uns auch beschäftigt
haben die ezb natürlich die könnte
tatsächlich so langsam auch ein bisschen
vorwärtsmachen im juni wird sie andere
aufhören die anleihekäufe fortzusetzen
und im juli so deutet sich langsam an
wird sie an die zinsen gehen und haben
jetzt bei der fed gestern erlebt die
märkte reagieren schon gar nicht mehr
verschnupft die wissen dass das kommt
und das ist auch angemessen und allzu
große zinsschritte werden wir nicht
erleben aber womit rechnen sie denn
somit würden sie dann rechnen wenn es da
eine erhöhung gibt im juni hatte ich
würde auf jeden fall damit rechnen dass
es einen kleinen ersten zinsschritt
mindestens in diesem jahr gibt es wird
sicher so sein dass die ezb die lage
jetzt beobachten wird wir haben ja eine
extrem unsichere lage wir haben
überhaupt keine vorstellung der zeit
davon wie sie sich tatsächlich was den
krieg betrifft weiterentwickelt und ich
könnte mir schon vorstellen dass die ezb
durchaus
mehr reagiert als wir bisher erwartet
haben in diesem jahr war eigentlich gar
kein zinsschritt erwartet jetzt geht man
schon fast sicher davon aus und wenn man
die inflation anschaut ist das auch
angemessen so langsam und wie gesagt die
märkte erwarten dass das geld muss
trotzdem irgendwo hin und wenn sie jetzt
einen kleinen zinsschritt machen werden
auch keine sparkonten günstiger als
vorher das heißt auch die aktienmärkte
werden in dem sinne nicht gleich
unattraktiver ok also es macht dann
trotzdem noch sind dazu investieren herr
meyer wenn wir jetzt
überlegen wo dann wenn wir sagen wie
kommen wo kommt denn demnächst das geld
her was wir alles brauchen dann hat man
natürlich mitten in einer steuerdebatte
und die ist ja auch in der
ampelkoalition ja auch schon hat ja auch
schon angefangen
naja was heißt sie hat angefangen wir
haben in der
koalitionsvertrag sehr deutlich
formuliert und das ist die position der
fdp nach wie vor dass wir
steuererhöhungen nicht mittragen werden
ich hatte es eben formuliert die steuer
und abgabenbelastung in deutschland für
privatpersonen aber auch für unternehmen
ist im oecd vergleich
an der spitze und wenn wir darüber reden
dass wir
zukunftsinvestitionen in diesem land den
letzten jahren versäumt haben dann
müssen wir uns sehr auch ehrlich machen
und sagen auch das kann der staat nicht
alles finanzieren sondern wir müssen
eigentlich dafür sorgen dass das kapital
was in dem land ist entsprechend auch in
zukunftsfelder investiert wird und
deswegen ist also jetzt eine
steuererhöhungsdebatte genau das falsche
was wir brauchen es gibt aber eine
debatte um steuern zu senken zum
beispiel die mehrwertsteuer
da sagt der landwirtschaftsminister sagt
wir könnten auch
bei dem thema sehr definiert
welche
produkte für einen temporären zeitpunkt
von der mehrwertsteuer ausgenommen
werden das ist alles eine und glaube ich
nicht am ende durchdachte idee wir haben
jetzt jeden tag jede woche neue ideen
die durchs dorf getrieben werden oder
wo am ende des tages man wenn man sich
genau anguckt die umsetzung sehr sehr
schwierig ist und deshalb
werden wir sicherlich nicht zur
reduzierten mehrwertsteuersätzen oder zu
anderen ideen kommen wie
gewinnabschöpfung steuern aber die das
ist eine andere sache haben wir noch mal
gut bei der mehrwertsteuer und senkung
von von steuer auf benzin und diesel
herr schneider wäre das finden sie das
sinnvoll zum beispiel die mehrwertsteuer
auf lebensmittel abzulenken überhaupt
nicht alles ist hat die gleiche dies
kann politik die wir mitmachen weil
diesel wird man es auch gar nicht weiter
gegeben wird bei letzten
mehrwertsteuerabsenkung 0 22
prozentpunkte ist bei benzin gerade mal
61 prozent beim verbraucher angekommen
eine zapfsäule in reste haben sich die
mineralölkonzerne
als sondergebiet eingesteckt das war
perfekt der letzten level
steuerabsenkung bei benzin dass man so
was jetzt wiederholt wundert mich schon
sehr deswegen von solcher dies kam
politik teuren gießkanne politik
überhaupt nichts wenn man tatsächlich
die haben es mal durchgerechnet dem
vorschlag folgen würde und da ging es um
gemüse hülsenfrüchte und obst wenn man
hier die mehrwertsteuer entfallen lassen
würde hätte der sozialhilfebezieher
eine entlastung von etwa vier euro im
monat
das ganze würde aber zwei bis drei
milliarden kosten und dann hängt das
damit zusammen halt im salz war der
hunger genauso billiger wird
und das macht letztlich kein zusammen
noch ein punkt zudem
zukunftsinvestitionen ich dachte sich
die fdp ja wirklich durchgesetzt schon
vor aufnahme der koalitionsverhandlungen
die festgeschrieben es gibt keine
steuererhöhungen und ich glaube das wird
dieser code so noch einen riesen ärger
bereiten denn wir müssen uns vor augen
halten dass ist durch corona ein
bisschen hinten ran gekommen und jetzt
durch diesen schrecklichen krieg erst
recht aber wir haben trotzdem nach wie
vor in den kommunen ein investitionsstau
für erhaltungsinvestitionen nicht keine
neubauten von
146 milliarden euro alleine 46 bei den
schulen 20 bin kindergärten 30
milliarden bei feuerwehren polizei
wir sind auf verschleiß gefahren das
jetzt auch
in absehbarer zeit beantworten müssen
wie sie damit umgehen will sie wird
entweder kredite aufnehmen müssen um
dort rein zu investieren oder aber sie
wird auch die schuldenbremse walter
aussetzen müssen wenn sie das bedienen
oder aber sie wird steuern erhöhen soll
sie hatte keine andere wahl alles andere
wäre gesund der fuß muss gesund zu beten
und das ist noch nie gelungen also wenn
sie sich die entwicklung der
verschuldung worüber haben wir ja
eingangs gesprochen in auf der
bundesebene angucken und die vergleichen
mit der verschuldungssituation auf
landes und auf kommunaler ebene muss man
sagen dass die korona krise einseitig
durch die bundesebene abgefedert wurde
das heißt wenn sie sagen dass wir
instandhaltungs aufgaben auf kommunaler
ebene schulen feuerwehr zettel haben
denn adressieren sie das bitte als
erstes mal an die bundesländer die sind
dafür originären nach dem grundgesetz
verankert wochen aber bereits geleert
oder das ist keine frage der ampel
sondern ist es zunächst erst mal eine
frage dass in den letzten jahren
und dann nehme ich keine konstellation
aus
einseitig immer mehr lasten auf den bund
verteilt oder abgedrückt wurden von den
ländern ja jetzt auch wieder so dass der
punkte wo auch wenn man sich ehrlich
machen mussten sagen muss die länder
müssen ihre hausaufgaben selbst aber
jetzt hat auch der bund auch abgeschoben
weil der bundes in der hand hat die
steuergesetzgebung so zu gestalten dass
lernte auch tatsächlich investieren
können dass das ist doch die länder
können
so gerne nochmal hören also steuer
erhöhen freiheit man wie viel sinn würde
das machen welche steuern könnte man
senken oder auf der anderen seite
mehrwertsteuer alter oder auf der
anderen seite eben auch steuern erhöhen
oder einführen die grünen sprach von
einer über gewinn steuer also krieg
konzerne die durch den krieg jetzt zum
beispiel gewinnen die sollen halt eben
noch mal besonders eben besteuert werden
macht so was sind
die frage ist in welchem moment
womöglich weil die wenigsten für einen
haushalt und dafür gibt es mehrere wege
natürlich zum einen kann man irgendwann
wieder sparen wir haben ein hat schon
gezeigt dass wir sparen können denn die
schwarze null hätten wir sonst so nicht
erreicht zum anderen klar man kann
steuern erheben aber es gibt auch die
dritte variante wenn sie die wirtschaft
zum brunnen kriegen dann spielen sie
steuern auch wieder ein die unternehmen
und die bürger die das geld verdienen
die zahlen ja steuern also es ist nicht
immer gesagt dass die steuer wirklich
durch eine steuererhöhung zustande
kommen muss und das muss ich einfach
zeigen und ich glaube das kann man heute
auch noch gar nicht genau sagen an
welchen schrauben da wirklich gedreht
werden kann wenn wir aus dieser krise
wieder rausgehen er führte sie wollten
auch gern das super sagt
ja also das thema vielleicht
mehrwertsteuer differenzierung also
differenzierte mehrwertsteuersätze das
wird immer wieder diskutiert und man
kann man kann diesen kampf nicht
gewinnen also wie bild der staat
entscheiden was man was man jetzt
reduziert oder was den vollen
mehrwertsteuersatz hat das sind wenn man
verliert sich da im klein-klein das
sollte man nicht beginnen und
grundsätzlich gilt gilt der grundsatz
strukturelle ausgaben müssen wir eben
steuerfinanzierten nicht also wir können
nicht immer mit der besucher kommen und
sagen das ist eine krise und und und
sozusagen mit geld das lösen das wird
nicht funktionieren also da wo wir
strukturelle probleme haben wachstums
defizite
müssen müssen wir letztlich über über
eine sinnvolle angebotspolitik auch
durch durch entlastung natürlich
mittelständischer unternehmen die
natürlich eine hohe gleichzeitigkeit an
belastung haben nicht also die
energiepreise die die grüne
transformation die digitale
transformation das ist eine hohe
belastung wir müssen eben dafür auch
raum schaffen und diese diese
transformation der wirtschaft die uns ja
allen hilft durch ein höheres
wachstumspotenzial in zukunft in dem
raum zu geben sehen sie da einen steuer
hören hier glaube ich nicht angezeigt
aber es gilt strukturelle ausgaben
müssen wir finanzieren aus der
gesellschaft heraus das können wir nicht
immer wieder machen durch
sonderprogramme
sondern müssen letztlich da sozusagen
durch durch eine steuerpolitik eben die
lasten gleichzeitig auch fair verteilt
also wenn sie sagen dass er macht keinen
sinn wenn wir immer mehr sonderprogramme
haben was er erwarten sie da mehr mehr
ehrlichkeit letztendlich von der politik
zu sagen so geht es eben nicht weiter
wir müssen jetzt eben alle da sind in
krisenzeiten da geht es nicht allen so
gut und da müssen wir jetzt sozusagen
durch ja
man kann immer in krisen kurzfristig
hilft erstmal damit kann man vieles
kaschieren aber das ist ja nur das
problem wir kommen ja von einer krise in
die nächste man muss sich ja auch mal
fragen warum ist das eigentlich so nicht
man hat frau merkel vorgeworfen immer
nur im krisenmodus zu sein und das
gleiche gilt auch für die neue regierung
die ja eigentlich gesagt hat wir wollen
mehr fortschritt wagen da scheint also
gar nicht so gar nicht so einfach zu
sein wenn man doch irgendwie fortwährend
krisen lösen muss und ich glaube muss
doch irgendwie sehen dass diese krise
eigentlich ausdruck einer einer einer
wenig konzeptionellen politik sind also
wir haben über 20 jahre ist für es
versäumt dinge zu gestalten in angriff
zu nehmen und also das unlängst auch
eine chance
wir sehen das ja die krisen präsentieren
uns ja die rechnung für für versäumnisse
in der vergangenheit eine
sicherheitspolitik ist eine außenpolitik
in der energiepolitik die rechnung
kriegen wir präsentiert und das müsste
doch eigentlich für uns der ansatz sein
zu sagen ab jetzt eben nicht mehr wir
müssen an die angebotsseite noch mal ran
sondern dass wir strukturell bestimmte
probleme überwinden und eben auch die
die wachstumsmöglichkeiten einer
demografisch alternden gesellschaft
wieder wieder stärken das ist vollkommen
richtig einerseits
wenn es brennt löscht man deswegen muss
man schon sagen dass letzten zwei jahre
im corona modus natürlich
im vordergrund standen bei all dem was
corona als letztlich brennglas der
versäumnisse auch schon gezeigt hat dass
wir hier vorankommen das gilt jetzt für
den ukraine krieg auch dass wir am ende
des tages jetzt zunächst erstmal diese
krisen
diesen diese krisen eindämmen müssen und
darauf reagieren müssen dass sie am ende
genau diese krise als chance begreifen
müssen und dazu kommen müssen dass die
versäumnisse die den letzten jahren hier
geschehen sind das die
ausgeglichen werden aufgeholt werden
müssen und haben jetzt schon mehrfach
gesagt und das ist glaube ich die chance
dieser ampel die natürlich nach wie vor
mehr fortschritt wagen möchte und ich
gehe auch davon aus dass das spätestens
im nächsten jahr gelingt denn nicht eine
neue krise kommt
ich denke da deutlichen völlig recht der
unterschied zwischen wirtschaftspolitik
und wirtschaftswissenschaft ist ja der
dass wirtschaftspolitik auf mehr
empfinden muss und wirtschaft dass
wirtschaftspolitisch passiert muss auch
von den bürgern und bürgerinnen
mitgetragen werden und dass die reine
lehre ist es nett aber hilft häufig
nicht deswegen finde ich dass man hier
in der korona krise auch schnell
reagiert hatte 2020 bereits halte ich
für sehr wichtig und für sehr wichtig
unabhängig dass wir davon mit einzelnen
maßnahmen wie etwa
mehrwertsteuerabsenkung kommt mit ich
nachvollziehen aber das ist dass man da
reagiert man kurzarbeit völliger sind im
nacht und verschiedene schutzschirm
gerade für kleine selbstständige machte
alles sind deswegen habe ich da denn ich
muss einfach sehen ist genauso wenn es
brennt muss man möchte punkt aber ein
anderer punkt noch
nicht mehr zusammenkommen
ich sehe das was die angebotsseite
angriff dann völlig anderes auch hier
wenn immer heißt wir müssen die angebote
immer wieder stärken das heißt im
klartext immer steuersenkungen sei es im
klartext immer sozialabgaben der kann et
cetera wenn man dann genauer was geplant
ist und es reden
konkret meint ich will ich da auf den
punkt heraus dass wir auch zur kenntnis
nehmen müssen dass alle während der
pandemie jahre haben die in deutschland
ansässigen milliardäre das 134 ihre
milliarden um 50 milliarden auf jetzt
fast 600 milliarden erhöhen können das
ist da das gilt wir müssen auch feste
richtig dass nach der ford studie haben
wir völlig neue situation so viel als
dass wir erstmalig mehr als
2700 millionäre in deutschland haben mit
anderen wurden wir haben luft denn
zwischen millionären milliardären
müssten auf jeden fall viel stärker ist
wie es wird immer viel von fernes
gesprochen bei der entlastung ich würde
auch gern von solidarität reden wir
kommen nicht darum herum starke
schultern wirst ja vorhin auch gehört
haben sie der grip zu belasten wenn wir
tatsächlich da er dafür sorgen wollen
dass wir auch nur fünfter
infrastrukturen denn wir haben
aber auf wessen von schulen brücken
straßen und andere marke passiert doch
schon meine wenn wir uns angucken wenn
die
wahrheit ist wenn wir uns angucken wie
die absoluten die absoluten zahlen sind
denn ist genau dieses bild dass starke
schultern mehr leisten mehr tragen ja
letztlich also sie würden sagen es gibt
nicht eine gruppe in deutschland die so
viel verdient dass sie noch etwas mehr
abgelehnt weil die natürlich auf der
anderen seite auch sagen muss dann sind
wir sehr schnell bei der debatte was ist
das für ein vermögen ist das
betriebsvermögen er schlicht gesagt
vermögen und wollen wir diese menschen
in deutschland halten und wollen wir
gucken dass wir mit den vermögen was
hier in deutschland liegt
arbeiten kennen und genau diese
modernisierung in dem land anschieben er
okay ich würde mussten bis auf die zeit
achten die letzten minuten gerecht
verteilen herr führen was sagen sie muss
man milliardäre millionäre wirklich
stärker besteuern muss dass diese
vermögenssteuer geben
ja das kann man natürlich also sollte
man dann dann wenn gesellschaften große
wird belastungen zu schultern haben dann
dann ist es so dann ist es aber der
ton von fairness dass das die ja aber
ich will noch mal auf einsteiger kommen
also angebotspolitik heißt dort nun mal
mitnichten dass wir die reichen reicher
machen wollen das ist ja das ja nun
wirklich quatsch oder angebotspolitik
heißt das wohl endlich diese
transformation
hinbringen müssen denn es geht doch
darum die angebote
produktionsbedingungen einer einer eines
veralteten an der veralteten
volkswirtschaft endlich zu erneuern also
wir wollen doch klimaneutral produzieren
darum geht es doch wir wollen digitale
wertschöpfung voranbringen das sind doch
die wachstumsquellen der zukunft meine
angebotspolitik zu interpretieren
als eine politik die den reichen noch
mehr aber dazu noch mal konkret meine
frage wenn die sagen in krisen muss man
eben dann solidarisch sein und muss man
halt eben müssen manche auch dann
vielleicht mehr zahlen wäre das dann
sinnvoll dass man sagt jetzt von
bestimmten vermögenden doch etwas einen
höheren beitrag zu wollen dem man dann
gezielt für was weiß ich klimapolitik
auch ausgibt
natürlich ist das so und das ist auch
teil der der wirtschaftspolitik dass man
natürlich immer gucken muss in einer
demokratie dass man sozusagen zustimmung
dafür bekommt und und und wenn jetzt
sozusagen ärmere haushalte bestimmte
branchen sehr stark belastet sind durch
durch krisen für die ja auch niemand
etwas kann jedenfalls nicht als
einzelunternehmen oder als
einzelhaushalt kann man sich dagegen ja
nicht irgendwo kann sich darauf nicht
vorbereiten und das sind ist ein risiko
aus der gesellschaftlich tragen müssen
und natürlich droht so etwas wie geld
westen proteste wie in frankreich das
ist eine reale gefahr also demokratie in
europa ist nicht nur von außen bedroht
sondern natürlich auch man solche
sozialpolitischen fragen von innen dass
er ja keine frage und das ist mit teil
der der wirtschaft und auch der
transformation politik sich um diese
menschen zu kümmern denn freiheit
manneck wie sehen sie es wäre gibt es
noch schultern in dieser gesellschaft
die einfach mehr also mehr tragen
müssten und mehr abgeben müssten
vielleicht könnte man diesen schultern
mehr möglichkeiten einfachere
möglichkeiten der investition beten das
ist sicher etwas was diesem land gut tun
könnte was auch eine art von
transformation wäre die wir dringend
brauchen
es ist immer noch schwierig möglich
instanz in unternehmen zu investieren
die nicht an der börse investiert sind
und das wäre natürlich ganz wichtig im
moment denn wir müssen unsere produktion
umstellen wir müssen unsere unternehmen
etwas umstellen wir haben diese
lieferketten probleme die uns gezeigt
haben dass wir anders produziert wir
müssen dass wir mehr zu uns holen müssen
dass wir lieferketten sicherer machen
müssen und eine möglichkeit wäre in der
tat auch gelder privat zu generieren
dafür um solche investitionen und solche
innovationen voranzubringen also ein
vorschlag dem sie sicher gut zustimmen
würden herr meier ich werden wir mit der
sogenannten super im nächsten jahr auf
den weg bringen das ist ja sag mal so
also ich wäre es salopp sehr salopp ein
bisschen ironisch formuliere wäre ich
dankbar schon mal wenn wir der lage
wären unsere schultoiletten langsam
herein zu investieren wenn wir in der
lage werden unsere maroden brücken mal
langsam instand zu setzen und wenn wir
in der lage werden 120000 pflegekräfte
zu finanzieren die wir dringend brauchen
weil wirklich am pflegebett helle not
ist dann wäre ich bereits lampen haben
das ist auch ein ganz wichtiger punkt
auch was er isst wachstum hemmt nämlich
der fachkräftemangel ist da ja auch ganz
wichtig wie lange ist die ampel sich da
weiter einig in diesen fragen wenn man
auf der einen seite sieht über
gewinnsteuersatz die grünen fordern
senkung der mehrwertsteuer und sie sagen
nicht wir haben ja noch keine also haben
ja nicht mal dann können kein konkretes
konzept was über gewinn steuer zum
beispiel angezogen wir haben letztlich
nur zeitungsmeldung und haben mehrere
meinungen in der öffentlichkeit dazu von
grünen politikern der koalitionsvertrag
gilt und ich glaube da haben wir eine
gute basis für die ampel und daran
halten sich auch alle parteien
unabhängig davon dass ich natürlich alle
unterschiedliche inhalte haben und
unterschiedliche meinungen auch in der
öffentlichkeit vertreten können auch
drei parteien die sich da einig werden
müssen aber bis jetzt war es ja ganz
harmonisch so zumindest steht es auch
auf der kabinettsklausur in meseberg
diese woche wir sind am ende dieser
sendung vielen dank herr schneider
vorhalt manecke vögel und herr meyer
vielen dank ihnen für das
zuschauerinteresse das war die phoenix
runde ich wünsche ihnen noch einen
schönen abend jetzt gibt es für nix der
tag abstand
[Musik]